Yle Areena.
(musiikkia)
käyttää suomen kieltä, joka on meille opetettu. Jospa presidentti, jos voisi olla esimerkki, ei taas ole muuten oikein mitään saa selville. Joka viides sana pitäisi katsoa sanakirjasta. Olkaa niin ystävällisiä, puhukaa suomen sanoja. Ei ne vieraskieliset sanasteista istään hieman työtä.
Eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan. Tällä kertaa jaksossa on luvassa ainakin asiaa liikenteestä, älypuhelimista ja kouluaineista. Jakson palikat on naputellut kohdilleen Koiviston Lauri. Eräs soittaja kertoo saaneensa huonoa palvelua parturissa. Toinen kansalainen taas tiedustelee, että maksaako sosiaalitoimi ihmisille älypuhelimet. Ja ehdotetaanpa myös yleislakkoa Suomeen.
Nyt on vuorossa murreasiaa. Nimimerkki murteet pois soittelee täältä. Mitäpä jos kansalaiset haluaisitte puhumaan ihan suomen kieltä, että saataisiin normaaliin kieltäkin puhua selvää teidän kamalista murteesta. Jos joku väittää, että murteet on rikkaus, niin paskaa puhuu. Murteet on aivan pitäisi olla kiellettyjen listalla. Voitaisiin tehdä kansalaisaloite, että murteet tässä kieltää kokonaan. Ei kukaan halua kuunnella erilaisia mommieruuksia.
Kyllä jokainen osaa puhuu ihan kirjakieltä. Se on opetettu koulussa ja sitä pitää pystyä myös puhumaan ilman, että tarvitsee niitä sanoja viennellä ja kiennellä. Kamalia murteita. Ai ai ai ai ai. Murteet pois, kiitos, hei!
Suomen ja Venäjän suhteita koskeva puhelu. Seuraavaksi siis siihen liittyviä ajatuksia.
On presidentti Niinistönkin niin. Sitä arvosteli, kun Niinistöhan sanoi siinä silloin jotain kun naamiet on riisottu niin jäljelleen sodan kylmä kasvat. Tämä on tyypillistä kommunistia, että on vanholtunut kansanradion kuuntelijoita. Siinä saadaan mielipiteitä sillä lailla esille, jotta eikä tarvita joka sanaa harkita, jotta uskallanko mennä vaan sanoa. Se on juuri näin kansanradiossaan kertoa mielipiteensä. Kiitos sinulle ja hyvää kevättä. Sitä samaa. Hei hei! Hei!
No, tervetuloa! Te oot täältä lähempää Itä Suomea kuin Länssuomea. Terve, terve. Kuuntelin tuosta ohjelman. Tuossa ajattelin on pakko soittaa. Siellä se herra mikä on niin kiinnostunut tuosta itänaapuri hyvyydestä ja muista oli pakko soittaa, että kyllä jos sillä miehenä on teelekkari, niin kyllä kannattaa katsoa vaikka tuota areenasta tuota taliini vallaten valletta. Mitä se teki? Miten hyvä poistettiin?
miten se valtio on perustettu ja miten se edelleenkin se sama tahti siellä jatkuu, niin sitten ehkä ymmärtää miten hyvä maa se tuo iso naapuri tuossa on. Oikein minua häämättyttivät vielä tuolta luontoisia ihmisiä, yleensä Suomesta löytyy.
Nyt tulihan sieltä rinkkisankkoja muuta aikana ja Karjalan väivät väkilisiä ja kaikki tämä silti se on hänen mielestäni hyvä maa niin kannattaisi pikkuisen kaston historiaa ja muuta ennen kuin tuota Jokka sai tietysti oma mielipide on mutta tämä on minun mielipide ja varmasti suurimman osa Suomea. Kiitoksia paljon tästä mielipideestä. Niin tuossa tää tuota. Suomessa on aina kumare tullut liian pitkin aina vikaasuuntaan ja nythän tää on ihan mahoton työn niin kun pitäis kumare tuon länteen ja itkään kohtaan hakota. Eihän tässä ollut aika pitkä jo oltu.
Näin sen puolella ei tule itseään kannalta että ei semmoista asiaa joo kiitoksia paljon tästä mielipideestä ja hyvä sanonta jatkaa. Kiitos samaa kiitos. Ei nyt on vuoro suunnata liikenneteemojen pariin. Ilmeisesti Turusta aloitetaan ennen puheluita vielä yksi postikortti ihan toisesta aiheesta. Siinä lukee näin. Hei kanssakulkijat. Vastaan Kuopion Paulille sillä hän on pohtinut puheluissaan syvällisiä aiheita.
Joihin haluaisin kirjoittaa omat ajatukseniin. Pauli kuolemaa ei tarvitse pelätä ja miehet saa itkää ja tuntea. On surullista että olemme eläneet aikaa jolloin pojat on kasvatettu olemaan kovia äijiä ja herkät pojat ovat joutuneet kuulemaan olevansa jollain tavalla vääränlaisia. Tällä on rakennettu rikkinäisiä ja katkeria miehiä jotka kärsivät koko elämänsä siitä ettei ole ollut lupaa olla olemassa.
Oma itsensä eli miehet ei tarvitse hävetä. Tällä tavoin luki postikortissa jonka meillä oli lähettänyt esimerkki Niska Järven rouva K kansanradioon voi lähettää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postiaosoitteeseen kansanradio pl seitsemänkymmentäyhdeksän nolla nolla kaksikymmentäneljä yleisradio.
Pussi riittää. Heippa. Hyvä Kanta radio.
No täällä on Marja tältä Mikkelistä. Moikka. - Moi moi.
Nyt ei ole kuule isot murheet, mutta tämmöinen kun kuulin tässä just mun sisko oli saanut kunnon kasteen tuolla tien päällä, niin autoilijat minusta tullut piittaamattomiksi kuralla täköistä.
Ja mulla oli ihan sama juttu. Tulin kaupasta yksi päivä kun nyt täällä paistaa aurinko Mikkelissakin, mutta ajo ihan suoraa semmoiseen ison lätäkköön, niin minä sitten kaikki ne kasteenani sain ottaa tuhannen loikkaa sivuun etten minä kastunut.
Eli autoilijoiden pitäisi enemmän huomioida jalankulkijat.
Nimenomaan, että mun siska sanoi kun hän asui vähän tuossa kaupungin ulkopuolella, mutta ihan tästä heti kun lähti, tuossa on tuo kenkävero. Sitä kautta menee sen Mikkelin puistokautta niin hän liikkuu aina jalkaisin, niin hän sanoi että hän oli aivan kura peitossa.
Hän sanoi että ei tee mie- kun minä pyysin vielä kun minä asun keskustassa niin hän pysyi käymään päiväkaavilassa, niin hän sanoi että nyt en kyllä lähi mihinkään, sain sellaiset kuraroiskeet taas yksi päivä ja ihan piihti, mutta hän sanoi että otit jo rekkarin ylös ja sanoi no ei näinhän minä nähnytkään mitään.
Kiitoksia kun soititte kerroit tämän asian.
Joo nyt siinä on vähän niinku, mut tulee mieleen kun mun yks suhlais oli kaksois pojat pienenä ja pistä turvaistuimessa, sinä oikein yllytti äitiä että aja äitillä täkkööni. Onks autoiluisi tullut niin lapsellisia et just on vaan hauskaa ajaa siihe piittaamatta muista. Jätä tämmösiin.
-Mukava sanotaan jatkoa. -Kiitos samoin sinne. Moikka.
-Joo tämä on mennyt kahden kinttiin äijätä pohjoispoliis. Morjes. -Morjes, morjes. -Lua vaan tuohon kiikastaan tuo Morihapanakin rata. -Joo siitä on nyt viime aikoina puhuttu. -Siitä on aika lailla valloseutu tuo ja nyt tuli taas lauhoito et väylävirast oli vissiin että ei se oo niinku mitään virkaisella ettei kannata tehdä. -Joo ja alueen kansanedustajat kyllä nosti vähän siitä ääntä että. -Juu, juu kyllä he otti vähän näköjään ja vähän kantaa ja mä olen sitemmä huomannut.
Olen ollut tässä kuljetusalalla kuusikymmentä viisi vuotta ja aina ollut kaiken näköjään ja tämäkin justi niin kuin Varkanosta nyt veres vedetään tukkisenkaan vedetään tän Porin jonkin sahoille niin se on aika lailla semmoista energiakuuntusta et sata kilometriä sivu. -Eli sinä olet vahvasti sitä mieltä että Pori-Haapamäki junarata pitäisi uudelleen avata. -Kyllä. -Tai osittain kyllä siis rakentaakin uudestaan eikä vaan ava. -Niin, joo mutta niin kun sanotte just niin se on kumminkin sen linjannus.
-Ja on vaan papaa että siellä ei ole mitään jätisenä. Mä nyt sanon jotakin et siellä on kaiken näköisiä esteitä jo mutta kai sinne esteet tuleeko uska kasvaa ympärille kun niitä traivata ja tuo tämä justi minusta niin on jollakin lailla sapettaa kun sehän olis just tämä poikittainen radat minun mielestäni jo just semmoisia vähetäs Tampereelta, Hellingistä, kaikkien ajet ruuhkia. -Että niinku hyviä puolia on monia. -Kyllä kyllä niin paljon et tuo et just tämä minusta.
Nyt tämä niin kuin tuo kummin välein liikenne niin se tekis paljo jo pari kaduastikin sais lasta tämä vaan puhutaan vaan tänne eikä tarvitse auton kiluttaa tän pori ja piti. -Kiitoksia paljon tästä puhelusta ja oikein hyvää sunnuntajatkoa sinne poriin. -Joo kiitoksia, hei.
kirjoituksen tästä tunnin junasta. Aivan älytöntä. Sinne laittaa ennemmin rahat kuin esimerkiksi sote:n tai muuhun. Siis tämähän on aivan kansanedustajien omaa etua ajaa vaan, että he pääsivät nopeammin töihin. Eikös niillä ole ne omat autot, mitkä ne auton kuljettaat vai onko ne vain pelkillä ministereillä, jotka ne vie ihan minne vain? Ja eikö tavan kansanedustajille
Tilaan sitten nämä taksijutut, niin mitäs ne enää tunnin junalla silloin tekee? Eipä minulla muuta. Kiitos ja oikein ihanaa kevättä kaikille kansanradion kuuntelijoille täältä keskeltä Suomea.
Kansanradion WhatsApp-sovelluksen kautta meille kansanradion voi laittaa WhatsApp-viestejä sekä tällaisia äänimuotoisia että myös tekstikommentteja. Kansanradion WhatsApp-numero on 044 551 5464.
Eli huonoa palvelua ja huonoa käytöstä. Ei muuta. Kiitos. - No hyvää päivää Mikkelistä. Kuulepa. Nyt näille kaupungin päättäjille sellainen viesti, että niihin parkkipaikkoihin, mitä kaupungilla on tienvarsilla, katujen varsilla, niistä näpit irti. Jos meinatte, että kivijalkakaupat pidetään pystyssä, ei niitä tarvitse pyöräteiksi enää tehdä. Nyt myös tarvitaan autoilta.
Niitä muutamia parkkipaikkoja, mitä siellä enää on jäljellä. Kiitos. - Minulla käy sääliksin sitä koiran omistaja raukkaaja, joka menetti hermusa täällä Oulun Alpilassa, kun ei saanut paskannuttaa koiransa taloyhtiön pihaalla, kun siinä on se kieltotaulu. Piti hermustuksissaan potkea ja kaata tuo kieltomerkki ja kohdakin oli jättänyt oma jälkensä siihen ja liikkuu vielä kusastut sien päähän. Täällä Alpilassa on paljon koiria ja koiria.
Ja kun olen jutellut heidän kanssaan, niin he pahoittelevat, että näiden muutamien takia leimotaan kaikki koiran omistajat paskojiksi. Voi kun nämä koiran omistajat tajuaisivat sen, ettei se ole koiran syy, mihin se räjansä tekee, vaan syy on siinä remmin yläpäässä. Otemppärä omoore.
Täällä on muun muassa Pohjois-Savosta. Minua harmitaan tämä yhteiskunnan melu ja mekastus ja tappelu. Kyllä katoin illalla tämän eduskunnan johtajien haastattelun televisiossa. Puhutaan, että ei puututa eläkkeisiin. Puututaan eläkkeisiin. Kymmenen tuhatta suurimmat eläkeläiset, niille lisätään veroa. Ei lisätä veroa, ei. Eikä puututa eläkkeisiin. Minä saan kolmesataa, kolmekymmentä euroa kansaeläkettä.
Kun työeläkkeeni tueksi pienen työeläkkeeni, niin minun kuukausikorotus oli kolme euroa kuukaudessa. Mihin minä sen tahan panen? Kaikki nousevat. Hinnat ovat nousseet älyttömästi ja ruuhahinta on raksutettava joka toinen lisähinto. Leita ei kuin pienemmän kaupassa, mutta hinta nousee. Niin mihinkä työ luulet, että tämän Suomen menevät? Ja myö eläkeläiset, kun ollaan tällainen turhake. Mutta onhan myös turhakeet maksettu veromme ja tehty työmme tähän yhteiskunnan.
Ja maksetaan edelleen veroja, mutta köyhiltä pienituloisilta ei kysytä, että otetaanko teiltä tai annetaanko teille. Meiltä vaan otetaan ja sille siis kiitos, hallitus. Ei muuta. Hei.
Joo, minäkin katselin ensimmäistä keskustelua. Mä ihmettelin, onko se niin hankala asia edes ottaa esille. Ei sitä tarvitse mitenkään kaltata. Me suomalaisina kansan ja maana olemme yksissä tuumin auttaneet Ukrainaa. Miksei kukaan huomaa sitä, että mitkä avustukset me olemme antaneet Ukrainaan?
Ei millään pahalla, mutta turha siellä on keskenään tehdä politiikkaa ja syytellä toisia puolueita. Yksissä tuumimme olemme avustaneet Ukrainaa. Se ei ole sinännään paha juttu, ei ollenkaan, mutta tää pitäisi ottaa huomioon, miten tästä eteenpäin. Se on näin. Kiitos.
Ja olihan hirveetä kuunnella aikuiset ihmiset päällekkäin puhumista, josta ei saanut enää selvää. Toimittaja joutui aina huomauttaa ja kenen vuoro. Ja sitten tää purra, että kun Lindtman kertoi asian ihan oikein, et minkään on niinku tää heidän hallitus hoitanut asioita, niin hän rupesi siinä syyttää niinkun. Mutta sehän on ihan siis puppua, siis purran puolelta. Ja toivon, että tää seuraava.
Niin olisi paljon viksumpi, viisaampi ja tekisi oikeita päätöksiä. Ja mä päätin, että en yhden ainoastaan vaalipaneelikeskustelua enää katso. Mulle riitti se siitä. Hyvät jatkot. Kiitos. Hei.
Nyt jatkamme muilla politiikka-aiheilla.
Pulina pois, että muut eivät pääse sitä sorkkimaan ja vaatimaan, että pitäisi antaa sinne tai tänne tai tonne. Se olisi todellista kansanvalta.
Kun nauraa, että hah hah hah ja hellumarei.
Saadaan rahaa ilman, että sitä kansala edes kerrotaan. Olisiko korkea aika, että kun tää viisasten kivi ei mene sitten nuorempaa ehkä vanempaa, tää saatikaan noin oppineeseen päähän. Lyödään täys syleislakko kiinni. Kiitos.
Viisas kansalainen tässä. Hyvää päivää. Näin se vaan kävi, että kansan edustajat nostivat itsellensä viisisataa euroa kuukausipalkkaa ja näin ollen he voivat ostaa nyt kallista polttoainetta ja myös sitä kallista ruokaa, joka vaan kallistuu kallistumistaan.
Tämä oli tiedossa ja hallitus ja kansanedustaja pepaas itselleen hyvän Pekin sillä lailla. No se on persaukinnen Päijät-Hämeestä 83 kun täällä soittelee aurinkoista kevättä ja keväthän on tällaista näköjään tällaista budjettiaikaa. Tuossa puhutaan paljon valtiontaloudesta ja menoista ja tuloista ja suomeksi sanottuna persaukisuudesta. Kuultaava Suomella ei ole rahaa mihinkään ja vanhukset on pakko tappaa vain pohjansa ja niin edespäin.
Kuitenkin kun asiaa vähän tutkii niin me ollaan laitettu Ukraina tukeen yli neljä miljardia euroa. Me ollaan koronaan laitettu se on kymmenen, viisitoista, kakskymmentä vähän laskentavasta riippuen. Sitten eilen tuli tuossa uutinen että ostettiin käytettyjä haupitseja Etelä-Koreasta niin pitkälti päälle puolella miljardilla euroa. Niin mitä nää sitten on nää rahat? Että onhan sitä rahaa ollut ja on nytkin ja tulee aina olemaan. Eikö tässä ole paljon rahaa?.
Ei ole kyllä mistään muusta kun et mihinkä se päätetään laittaa. Ne on mitä harvovalittuja sitten. Tämä kuvi näin tunnelmii kippin tatsia mukavaa kevättä.
No pattiota vaan soitteli Reksa terve. Juu että tuota niin Ukrainan valissa rahaa ja hinnat sen kun nousee. Älkääpä sitten kysykö että mistä johtuu ongelmat? No eipä tässä kuule sen kummempaa. Kiitoksia tästä ihanasta EU:sta. Heippa.
No meinaa täältä vammalaista niin viime tellen tätä pääpälle on ollut että ohjuksia pitäisi yliopistoja pitäisi Suomen kamaroille tuoda kun ne varmaan kriisitilanteessa niitä tulee ihan tarpeeksi tänne siis muualta niin että tähän nyt sijoittaa tarviin. Nyt paikkansa varmaan löytää sitten kun on ne vauhattaminen niin tämä oikeus hallitus niin kaikki ollaan Naton ylätä niin kaikki ollaan nuet väisi. Ei muuta. Ei muuta nyt onkin paikallaan vaikka Eurooppa.
Ei muuta nyt onkin paikallaan vaikka Eurooppa.
Luokkiin asetettu että ne joilla on älypuhelin niillä on mahdollisuus kaikkeen päättää mutta ei esimerkiksi semmoisella vanhalla omaishoitajalla ole mahdollisuutta päästä jolla ei ole älypuhelinta. Tämä asia minua hirveesti vaivaa että kertokaa viisaat ihmiset minulle miksi maailma on tämmöiseksi mennyt. Kiitos ei.
sosiaali toimista nuo älypuhelimet niille joilla ei ole rahaa itse ostaa. Nehän on uusittavakin kahden vuoden päästä ja aika arvokkaita. Mistä ihmeestä ne reppii tuota rahaa jotka ei töissäkään kule niin ne vaan älykännykkää pyöritelle että ihmetellä pitää mistä moiset vehkeet tulee. Mutta eihän se raha lopu jos vaan tekijät ei kuole.
No niin yks hän etelä vielä soittelee, että kuinkahan monta sataa työntekijää lähtee lääketehtaasti ja lääketeollisuudesta ja apteekseistä lähtivät työttömäksi, jos eläkkeesta aletaan leikkaamaan? Siitos.
Ei vaan kaikki kansalaiset. Kuuntelin juuri rariota, jossa kerrottiin, että Suomessa ei edes ole siinä tasolla syöpähoitojen tutkimuksissa ja hoidossa kuin muualla. Eroskunta voisi nyt ruveta tekemään töitä ja lopettaa sen toisten puolueiden haukkumiseen.
Sopii hyvin muistuttaa, että Kansanradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan joka perjantai kello kaksikymmentäyksi. Jos merkkaat sydämenkuvasta ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellonkuvasta, niin saataina ensimmäinen tiedon kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Kuunnella kun olen ajatellut, että ne ovat toisto, toisto, toisto ja höpö, höpö, höpö. Mutta nyt kun luin tämän sivun, niin alan pahan joka pyhä kuuntelemaan sen. Älä nyt sitä tee muille. Tee ihan niin kuin sinä olet alkujaan ollut kiinnostunut meitä vanhoja riittää kuuntelemaan sunnuntaiaamuisin tuosaa. Kaiken lisäksi niin kuin sanoit, olet ollut kiinnostunut näistä.
On noin jutuista joku piliuta viekö. Tää tähti lyysä ole jatko. Miks etkä niitä pala niihin? Oki paljon kidempaa, mutta joka tapauksessa nyt pyydän anteeksi. On ollut vähän aikaa tuossa kiippannut, mutta nyt hänen laitakaan kiinni. Tämä oli kiva luku. Jukra viekö. Kiitos paljon. Paljon onnea. Jatka laittaa. Vähän joukkoon sinne.
Joo, ja sitten vähän voit laittaa sinne kans. Minun mielestäni luusia nekrojakin voi vähän laittaa. Tarkoitan tietysti saulia nekrospirituaaleja. Odotan nytte oikein innolla. Katsotaanpas mitä tapahtuu sunnuntaina. Kuuntelen kiva. Kiitos.
Tarkasterve jälleen kerran. Kuule kukahan noita televisio ohjelmia tuolta noita niin valitse tuolla teläkkäriin että minkä takia ei voi tulla semmoisia kuin vanhoja kom- tai ei nyt vanhoja, mutta komediasarjaa kuin esimerkiksi Mooseksen perintö, Bergamarin pojat ynnä muuta. Siihen sarjaa kuuluu monta monta sarjaa. Minkä takia niitä ei voida lähetää sitten televisiossa? Ja hirveesti katsojia varmasti riittäisi. Terveisiä täällä kuka näitä valitsee näitä.
Hyvä, kiitos, moi!
Kaunis kiitos yhdestoista neljättä Ethno-illasta Yle Radio Ykköselle. Ohjelma oli liian lyhyt. Musiikki on useimmiten etnomusiikissa pitkää ja kertomukset myös pitkiä. Näitä pitäisi olla enemmän, jotta olisi muutakin kuin kotimaista ja suomalaista musiikkia tarjolla.
Toivoisin kaikenlaista. Erittäin hyvä ilta. Kiitollinen, että moni muisti romaneita, romaniväästöä ja näitä pitäisi olla enemmän. Toivoisin, että olisi etnomusiikkitunteja vaikka, jossa ei näitä etno-iltoja olisi Afrikasta, latinalaisesta Amerikasta sieltä ja täältä. Myöskin Aasiasta. Pehkeä semmoinen etnotunti, jossa ei ole eurooppalaisia välttämättä.
Toivottavasti kuluaineista päättävät ovat nyt kuulolla. Kohta tulee teille ehdotuksia uusiksi oppiaineiksi. Niitä ennen vielä yksi televisioon liittyvä Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella lähetetty teksti, jossa lukee näin:
Samat naamat näkyvät viikko tolkulla. Niihin jo kyllästyy. Toinen juttu on uutisten jälkeen tulevat kolme uutistrippiä. Ne menevät niin nopeasti, että ei ehdi lukea, että tämmöistä asiaa.
Tämän tekstin oli meille lähettänyt nimerkki Pernion äijä Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella. Tekstimuotoisia kommentteja voi lähettää lomakkeen lisäksi myös sähköpostilla. Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on:
kansan.radio@yle.fi. Minä ehdottaisin vähän uudistuksia noihin kouluaineisiin. Esimerkiksi vuorovaikutustaidot ja käyttäytyminen ovat nykyajan lapsilta täysin hukassa. Ne käyttäytyvät tosi väkivaltaisesti toisia kohtaa. Jopa opettajia uhkailevat, niin nyt tarvitsisi tuota tehdä asialle jotain ehdottomasti. Elikkä vuorovaikutustaitojen opettelua koulussa ja käyttäytymistä. Miten kunnioitetaan ja käyttäydytään kanssaihmisiä kohtaan. Sitten on terveyskasvatus erittäin tärkeä.
Esimerkiksi tämä, että olisi liikuntatunteja enemmän ehdottomasti. Minä ehdottaisin, että joka päivä olisi liikuntatunti. Ja sitten on tämä kiireetön ruokailuhetki myös erittäin tärkeää oppilaille, ettei hotkittaisi sitä ruokaa, vaan että ne saisivat syödä ihan rauhassa pureksimalla ja pieniä annoksia mielellään kerrallaan ja terveellisiä ruokia.
Sitten minä ehdotan myös käytännön taitoja koululaisille. Arkiaskareisiin käytännön taitoja. Nämä käytännön taidot estävät niin sanottua uusavuttomuutta. Opetettaisiin esimerkiksi siisteyttä, että miten siivotaan oma huone. Sitten oppilaat voisivat olla esimerkiksi mukana terveellisten ruokien valmistamisessa koulukeitiössä. Ja siitä olisi paljon hyötyä niille, kun he oppisivat tekemään terveellisiä ruokia ja saisivat sitten kotona vanhiemillekin kertoa, että tuli tehtyjä koulussa näin terveellisiä ruokia, että tehdäänpä yhdestäkin kotona näitä samoja ruokia.
Niin tämähän parantaisi tätä kansantervettäkin huomattavasti, kun jo lapsesta asti opetettaisiin näihin taitoihin.
- Täällä on mummu Espoossa. Ja kuule, mä oon tota noin nyt Engonen papereita, yli sata vuotta vanhaja papereita. Hieman mielenkiintoisesti. Muun muassa mä löysin mun vanhempien todistuksia. Isä on käynyt Helsingistä normaali-risota ja äiti Pohjanmaalla yhteiskoulu. Kuule, niillä on ollut semmoinen aine kuin kirjanpito koulussa.
- Minusta se on ollut hirveän järkevä tuo kirjanpito, että tänään tässä moni ei osaa laskea, miten paljon rahaa niillä on, että tuo kirjanpito on ihan järkevä, että pitäisi tänäänkin päivän alla kouluissa.
- No niin, eli siinä tuli selvä ehdotus, että nykypäivän kouluun kirjanpito oppii aineeksi. Kiitos paljon tästä ehdotuksesta.
Joo, kiitos. Joo, hei hei.
Kaksikymmentä alkaen tuossa numarossa vastaa ihmisvastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Joka uudesta aamusta kuitenkin suurta luojaamme kiittekää iloiten hyvää kevättä.
No nyt kun Suomessa on tää liikkumattomuus niin kauhean paljon yleistä, -
niin voisiko järjestää Suomessa tällaisen maratoonitapahtuman, missä olis myös juukkikset juoksemassa.
Eli tällainen oikea kunnon tällainen kunnon show pystyy, että se olisi bändejä, minkä soittelisi ja kaikkien mahdollista keksittäisi.
Ja sitten valtion kannattaa sijoittaa, siis on kaksisataaviiskyt tuhatta, että saisi lahjakortteja noihin kauppoihin.
Niin mä epäilen, että jos sais vaikka viientuhannen euron tai kymmenen tuhannen euron lahjakortin kun maratoni juossaan, -
tai tällainen arvonta, että palkintorahoja on kaksisataaviiskyt tuotta, niin niitä arvotaan kaikkien juoksijoitten kesken, -
ei pelkästään niitä, mitkä tulevat ensimmäisenä maaliin. Ja näitä julkiksia sinne juoksemaan, näitä eri musiikin alan ja kaikkien tällaisia juoksemaan, -
niin sillä tavalla saataisiin houkuteutua ihmiset lenkeilyyn. Tämä voisi vielä joillekin ihmiselle jäädä tämä lenkeily.
Kun en huomaan kuinka kiva asia on, että tämä tää on kannattanut Suomessa nyt tehdä, tei muun muuta. - No niin, jokkaannehan tietää ja on kuulu, että miten korppi ääntää metässä. Ja ne, jotka eivät ole kuuluneet, avaannan näytteen, miten korppi ääntää. Se vanhoaa yleensä näe, että gene vanha, karva lakki, lakki, lakki, lakki, lakki, lakki, lakki. Kiitoksia. - Haluan kiittää kaikkia vegaaneja. Olette ainoa elämän puolesta, -
toimiva ryhmä tästä tekopyhien ihmisten maailmassa, ette aiheuta kärsimystä ja kuolemaa, kuten aivan kaikki muut. Upeaa epäitsekästä muiden puolesta toimimista. Iso kiitos kaikille vegaaneille.